stéphane rozès merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors on parlait
éventuellement un du mois de juin pour
un second tour
cette fois pour vous est-ce que c'est
clair le second tour des municipales
n'aura pas lieu avant les vacances d'été
non il n'y a rien de ferme d'ailleurs on
avait dit à juste titre tel que le
rapporte également de jdd de ce matin le
projet de loi a été transmis
officieusement au conseil d'état mais
comme vous l'avez dit également l'idée
que si c'est reporté à l'automne
les résultats de la municipale à risque
d'être faussé pour les municipales ou
lemieux maire n'a pas été du pardon dès
le premier tour
parce qu'au fond est considéré qu'au
delà de trois mois on fausse la logique
de ces mêmes municipal du court au fond
est-ce que ce serait une solution juste
finalement de se refaire les premiers et
les seconds tours à l'eau à l'automne
comme il semble se dessiner aujourd'hui
oui pour moi c'est absolument juste
pourquoi parce qu'un vote n'est pas un
acte administratif c'est un acte de
nature politique
nous sommes avec des scrutin majoritaire
à deux tours et c'est une sorte de
riposte laïque que de voter en france
mus par la dispute commune premier tour
c'est chacun se distinguent
chacun court sous ses propres couleurs
et au deuxième tour il faut essayer de
rassembler donc c'est une alchimie très
précises et on ne peut pas ce point
déconnecté le premier tour un moment
avec des enjeux des représentations
mentales des français qu avant là haut
débit pour faire ensuite un deuxième
tour où ce qu'on a en tête les citoyens
au moment où ils vont voter sera par la
force des choses changer pour faire un
machin comme disait le pédagogue piaget
un vote à deux tours c'est un peu comme
un arbre on peut pas le coupé entre
hanches on peut pas découper l'arbre en
tranches et remettre ensuite étranges
les unes au dessus des autres et dire
que c'est un arbre et bien pour une
élection à deux tours c'est la même
chose on peut pas couper en tranches le
premier et le second tour
tout ça se fait dans une même logique
dans une même dynamique dans un même
rite démocratique laïque de sorte que le
deuxième tour est forcément l'émanation
d'une dynamique du premier qu'on ne peut
pas distinguer les deux à ce point et du
coup dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire
il faut tout de même garder les maires
qui ont été élus dès le premier tour en
mars dernier oui absolument parce que
les mères qui ont été dus dès le premier
tour le contrat au contrat fixe et sert
en général des petites des moyennes
communes bien sûr le celui qui a été élu
s'est présenté avec un contrat et tout
de suite les citoyens mois des raids
majoritairement à ce contrat il n'y a
pas de raison que le lien entre les
électeurs et le maire et son équipe soit
entaché le lien a été fait il est tenu
il a été validé par tous dème soir de
l'élection le lendemain il n'y a pas de
raison de défaire ce lien par contre là
où les maires n'ont pas été au second
tour
il n'y a aucun lien il ya seulement un
mode qui a eu lieu au premier tour mais
qui n'a pas achevé sa dynamique a été
avorté et donc ce qui importe c'est
évidemment le mécanisme dans sa
procédure démocratique lui même et puis
l'esprit même du vote ce que des gens
intériorise au moment où ils vont voter
et ça doit être dans un même mouvement
entre le premier et deuxième tours donc
pour libérer du le premier tour le
contrat a été présenté le contrat était
nouée il n'y a absolument aucune raison
de revenir sur cela alors une dernière
question il ya la vie du conseil
scientifique qui a attendu le 23 mai
notamment pour savoir si on peut
rejouer le second tour au mois de juin
qu'est ce que vous en attendez de cet
avis du conseil scientifique
honnêtement la vie de concessions le
conseil scientifique étaient des
autorités médicales
avec quelques autres qu'il avait à dire
des choses au plan sanitaire
mais c'est aux politiques de trancher
la vie sans terre et sans doute porté
n'ont pas atteint sur le report mais sur
est-ce que le deuxième tour peut avoir
lieu avant l'été
et c'est là où son avis est important
même si on peut émettre des réserves sur
ce même conseil qui avait donné son feu
vert pour le premier tour des
municipales temps ce type de décision
d'un absente fait de savoir s'il avait
raison pour des raisons sanitaires
le vrai sujet c'est bien un sujet
politique et la symbolique du maintien
du premier tour alors qu'il fallait se
mobiliser contre la pandémie était
désastreux nonobstant ce qu'ils ont pu
attraper la pandémie durant ce premier
tour donc chaque chacun doit faire son
travail
colosse conseils scientifiques fassent
correctement son travail
ça n'a pas été le cas dans le passé on
le sait maintenant sur un certain nombre
de sujets dont qu'il émette un avis
sanitaires sur le fait de savoir si le
premier tour peut avoir lieu avant les
élections mais on dernière instance
c'est normal ce sont les gouvernants
c'est le politique qui doit avoir le
dernier mot en la matière en un mot le
conseil d'état pour éclairer tentait
qu'il le fasse bien et sérieusement mais
ensuite c'est le politique qui tranche
toujours selon un principe de précaution
ce qui n'avait pas été le cas au début
de la pandémie
lorsque la question des municipal
s'était posée merci beaucoup stéphane
rozès d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes président de
le cap c'est le conseil analyses et
perspectives merci